welcome
back to day two of the clinical oncology
track of the asia pacific japan
genetic solution tour 2020
i'm ray i'm back and i'm the moderator
for this session
today we will continue to discuss the
clinical oncology topics
around microsatellite instability and
liquid policy
application which is of high interest in
the last
few years
so for our first speaker
we'll hear from dr charles cardo
who is a molecular biologist in the
genetic sciences division
clinical vertical as a thermal facial
scientific
and his development efforts are focused
on oncology application
recently he was the lead developer
on the applied biosystem truemark
msisa a new msi
detection kit with an expanded marker
set and automated analysis
for complete biography on our
speaker please visit the tab
at the top of your screen today
sabato will be sharing with us some of
his work
and to showcase combination of our
expanded panel and automated analysis
software
constitute an important tool for
studying msi
if any question arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your question
following
his presentation please join me
in welcoming dr bottle now
i will turn the presentation over to him
thank you for that introduction hello
and
thank you for joining this webinar today
my name is charles baudo and i'm an r d
scientist at thermo fisher scientific in
the genetic sciences division
clinical vertical our job is to develop
content across
the infectious disease and oncology
space and today i will show you
an oncology application a fragment
analysis test
to detect the presence of microsatellite
instability
or msi and tumors first i'm going to
give you a background on what msi is
describe the detection method that we
have developed over the past two years
and detail the performance of the kit on
clinical research samples
but first some background on micro
satellite instability
in 1997 bethesda guidelines were
established
with the main goal of standardizing
microsatellite instability testing
and in an inherited form of colorectal
cancer
turned to lynch syndrome in 2004 those
criteria were revised because the
original guidelines included
dinucleotide repeats and these were
found to be less sensitive
until 2017 micro satellite testing was
mostly performed to identify cancers
with
inherited mutations in genes that affect
dna mismatch repair
however with the approval of ketruda and
other immunotherapies
micro satellite testing has become even
more prevalent
as any deficient mismatch repair
or micro satellite instability high
cancer could be treated with these drugs
msi testing has been traditionally done
using
immunohistochemistry or through
fluorescent pcr
followed by fragment analysis on
capillary of electrophoresis instruments
the figure here shows a fragment
analysis result of five mononucleotide
markers
the x-axis in this figure is the
amplicon size
and the y-axis is fluorescence the top
panel is the normal tissue
and the bottom panel is the tumor tissue
and the normal tissue we see one set of
peaks associated with a marker
here and the same set of peaks in the
tumor sample
also in the tumor sample here we see a
second set of stutter peaks which
is associated with a deletion in this
amplicon
and so you and so this phenotype here is
micro satellite instability
on the next slide i'll show you what we
are actually measuring in micro
satellite unstable tumors
microsatellite instability is the change
in length
of small repeat units in the genome in
this diagram
on the top we can see an eight
mononucleotide repeat example
here on the left side of the diagram
mismatch repair proteins identify
polymerase slippage
that happens during dna replication and
corrects the number of repeat units
we begin with eight and we end with
eight
and this is considered microsatellite
stable
however on the right replication
slippage results in the number of repeat
units changing from eight to four
and the replication error is missed
due to deficient mismatch repair
proteins this is called
micro satellite instability
it's really important to study msi
because there are cancers with inherited
mutations and genes that
affect dna mismatch repair turn to lymph
syndrome
and many people do not know that they
have these mutations
an individual with lymph syndrome has an
increased lifetime risk of developing
colorectal endometrial and other cancers
it's also important to study
for immunotherapy research deficient
mismatch repair
repair results in mutations throughout
the genome which produce neoantigens
that prime an immune response
in the presence of immunotherapy drugs
this slide
the next slide shows the mechanism of
action for this
in general microcytoides ability
correlates with
higher mutability in the tumor cell here
in panel a
it shows a tumor with mismatch repair
deficiency that produces neoantogens
caused by a frameshift mutation
throughout the genome but pdl1
pd1 interaction between the tumor and
the t cell
blocks the activation of the t cell and
blocks the clearance of the tumor
so in panel b
we have the presence of a immunotherapy
drug that binds either pd1 or pdl1
allowing the t-cell to recognize the
neo-antigen here
and to clear the tumor cell
on the left we have the kaplan-meier
curve that shows the overall survival of
patients with
pdl1 drugs and
in microsatellite high or micro
satellite
stable patients and you can see that
micro satellite instability high
patients
do better than micro satellite stable
patients
the figure on the right on the y-axis
shows
micro satellite instability frequency
and on the x-axis various cancer types
the three cancers with the highest
around 20 to 30 percent
ms high high frequency are colon stomach
and endometrial cancers
and these are the three sample types
that we performed analytical validation
on our kidney which i'll show data for
later
so the next few the remainder of the
talk will actually focus on
the background of what our
kit uh what is included in our kit and
the performance of it
here are the key features of it um so in
the beginning i showed a tumor and
normal sample run on fragment analysis
with this kit you don't have to run the
normal control although
you can um
it after you do your fluorescent ptr you
take
the file that comes off the capillary
electropores with instrument and import
it into our software and it'll
automatically make an overall call in
that sample if it has
micro satellite instability or not in
the chemistry of the kit we have
13 msr markers which is eight more than
the predominant assay on the market
right now
plus two simple identification markers
pentad
and th01 these are included so that if
there are any simple mix-up or
contamination in
your tumor or normal samples you can
identify those
you only need two nanograms of ffp dna
so very little amount is used
for this assay and you can get results
in as little as four
hours with less than a one hour hands-on
time
we performed analytical validation on
the sig studio and 3500
series but we have customers that are
also running it on the 3730
and are showing really good results the
software that i mentioned
that comes with the kit is provided at
no additional cost
here's the workflow for the chemistry
after you've extracted the dna from the
ffd samples you
is a 15 minute pcr sample prep you take
that put it on a thermocycler for two
hours
and then another fragment analysis
sample prep
run that on the capillary
electrophoresis instrument
take the fsa file and import it into our
software in four hours you've got your
overall call
here are the msi markers that are
included in the kit eight of them are
publicly known msi markers some of these
are the bethesda markers
some of these are markers
known in the literature or previously
used to detect microsatellite its
stability
in multiple different cancer types we've
also included
five mfa markers proprietary to applied
biosystems
that were shown to be quasi monomorphic
which means that they have the same
allele across
multiple epic populations and that's
really important in the tumor only a
mode
and um they were also shown to be
extremely sensitive in multiple
different cancer types
these are the two simple identification
markers
pencil d and th01
pentadie is a pencil nucleotide repeat
and tho1 is a tetranucleotide repeat
here i'm showing a representative
co-rectal carcinomas
figure on the left is the tumor and on
the right is the normal
here are these are all of the different
dye channels here there are five
different ones
fanfic med taz and sid
and you can see here in the tumor sample
an extra set
of peaks that represent smaller
amplicons or deletions
in the tumor sample at each of the
different msi markers
here and here and others and
this these um two distinct
uh um peaks here are the
sample identification markers and you
can see that they're the same allele
in both the tumor and normal which
lets you know that these both came from
the same sample
or from the same individual
so we performed analytical validation on
greater than
150 research samples from colorectal
gastric and endometrial cancers and i'm
going to show
a few examples of these on the next
slide
so here are examples of deficient
mismatch repair
msi high colon gastric endometrial
research samples
and once again you can see that this
very distinctive deletion
in the tumor sample for in the colon
and gastric and and the endometrial
samples here
so the next two a few slides are going
to show examples of
why we wanted to develop an automatic
calling algorithm and software
so this uh is a colorectal
research cancer sample and i'm showing
the fam channel and it's in a case of an
example
it's an example of an obvious and subtle
micro satellite instability
so on the x-axis once again we have the
amplicon size from small to large
and on the y-axis we have the peak
height or fluorescence
in blue the normal and the green is the
tumor and here you can see
an eight base pair separation between
the normal sample
and the tumor sample so this example
here
is really obvious
in nr21 the difference between the
tumor and normal is only one base pair
and so this can be
really difficult to make a call by the
human eye
so that's why we wanted to develop a
algorithm that can do this for you
to detect these really challenging cases
we also developed
synthetic contracts to help train the
algorithm
and to help give an example of uh how
these small
smaller deletions are really challenging
to detect by the human eye
so uh in this example the tumor is blue
and the normal is black
and all of these examples are from one
marker i believe it's nr21
at twenty percent variant allele
frequency so at five space
about five phase pairs 20 vaf you can
rightly see
the extra set of peaks but as you
decrease in the base pair deletion size
that is increasingly hard to detect by
the human eye
so having an algorithm that can detect
these smaller deletions is really
helpful
here i show the results for the tumor
normal analysis let me back up we
actually have
two different algorithms in the software
one for tumor normal analysis so if you
provide the normal sample and a
tumor sample and we
used those greater than 150
gastric endometrial and colon samples to
tune and train with the algorithm to
maximize sensitivity and specificity
on both the 3500 and seek studio genetic
analyzers
and you can see that we have a really
good area under curved score here
across each of these different sets of
data which represent
groups of data with different base pair
deletion sizes
this slide shows the performance of the
algorithm
in tumor-only analysis so we're not
using a normal sample here
and on the x-axis you can see the
estimated deletion size and on the
y-axis you can see the sensitivity
and as you increase the deletion size
you
increase your sensitivity which is which
makes sense it's
hard to detect very subtle deletions of
one base pair in um without having a
normal sample
and that's relevant because in
endometrial samples
those roughly 20 of endometrial samples
have
really subtle deletions of around one to
two base pairs
and so we recommend not using tumor-only
analysis in this particular sample type
this is more amenable to colon and
gastric samples
and we have comparable performance
between both of the platforms 3 500 and
6 studio
this slide shows the concordance between
our pcr-based assay
and aminohistochemistry so we performed
immunohistochemistry and all those 150
samples that i mentioned
and in uh here we can see that we have
around
a 90 coordinates between the true mark
msi
assay and the ihc
this is a good result because roughly
fifty percent
of the samples in the data set are
extremely challenging it's those
endometrial samples that i mentioned
that have really subtle deletions that
have been historically hard to detect by
ptr
because there's only a one to two base
pair shift and we're detecting them
at a really good level this next
slide compares the performance between
the promega msi test
and ihc and you can see that
their system has an 83 percent accuracy
or much lower than the true mark msi
test
and the promega test had roughly 17 no
calls
and in the true mark msi assay was able
to make
for a colon 14 of those 17
samples so our assay was more robust
and more accurate one of the reasons why
the r assay was more accurate is because
the promega assay only uses
five markers and didn't perform as well
in those endometrial samples
so having those additional markers on
the true mark mfa assay allowed us to
pick up
those small instabilities that were
missed by the promega system
i'm going to pivot now to describing the
software and the various features within
the software that
are available so firstly the software
only works with the trumark msi
assay and it allows for automatic
calling of markers
and samples and you can use
a tumor normal or just a tumor sample
to make those automatic calls there are
qc
features in there and if you want you
can have review and auditing
there are individual specimen reviews
and
batch views and you can export these
specimen reports
and batch reports in various different
format types
if you would like to download the
software you can download it from
thermofisher.com msi software
here on the right is a picture of a
specimen
and this is a specimen data view looking
at the fam
channel there are three markers in the
same channel here on the top is the
tumor sample on the bottom that's the
normal
and you can see an extra set of peaks
clearly in the tumor sample here
and on the right the call is correct for
each of these different samples
you can make a manual call if you
disagree with this automatic call
and i'll show an example of that on the
next slide
in this particular example once again we
have the
tumor on top and the normal on the
bottom
this is in a different channel with four
different markers in it
here we have the automatic call as
stable for abi 17
here and we can visually see that there
is an extra set of peaks
i would go ahead and call this micro
satellite unstable for this particular
marker
and you can modify that over here in the
manual call section
and it'll update this unstable call for
the
specimen at the top so if you disagree
with any of the automatic calls
you can change them here's a stacked
view where the tumor
is displayed over the normal but you can
also click this button here to overlay
the tumor and normal
to confirm that this is indeed a micro
satellite unstable
marker and here's what that looks like
the
normal is in blue or i'm sorry it's in
brown
and the tumor is in blue and you can
clearly see that extra set of stutter
peaks
in the tumor sample and we can go ahead
and confirm
this manual call change
these are the two different report
formats that we have you have a specimen
level report and a batch summary report
in the specimen level report it
tells you for that specimen how many
markers were unstable
stable or were the algorithm was unable
to make a call in and the reported
unstable rate
if you made any comments on here about
the sample
you those would show up right here it
also has the marker details where the
electro ferrograms for each of the
individual markers
and their call are displayed here as
well
for review and you can see whether or
not the hid markers
are the same between the tumor and
normal so that there's no sample
contamination in the report there are
also other metadata information
on the analysis version of the software
and
some other features in the batch summary
report
if you run you know a full plate of
samples you can get an overall
a quick view for the overall call of
each of those individual samples on
there
if there were any warnings how many
unstable or stable
calls there were whether or not it was
able to make a match between the sample
identification markers
if you reviewed it if you've edited it
at all
that's all exportable in multiple
different formats pdf csv
so in summary the truemark msi essay
achieves robust identification of msi
with low sample input
and we developed the software that has
that is really quick and
it has high sensitivity and specificity
in calling
micro satellite instability
you can also use this assay and software
without a normal in colony gastric
research samples
which cuts down the cost of sample in
half if you want to learn more about the
essay you can visit the website here at
thermofisher.com
msi and with that i will take any
questions that you have
thank you for your time
thank you dr baudel for that outstanding
presentation we will now move
into the live q and a portion of the
presentation
as a reminder please submit your
question
about the q a blog
there are several questions coming in
now let's take a look at the first one
how do you compare msi
on singer
on ngs
great first question yeah i think msi
has
on singers has two big advantages
one is it's cost it's really cheap and
it's technologically easy
to perform but you can also physically
see the evidence
of the instability on an
electro-ferrogram you can
make that judgment call for yourself and
look at those peaks and compare them
between your tumor and normal samples
and
truly see that it is unstable or
unstable
on ngs you get you have a you know an
arbitrary
ngos cutoff score and you can't
physically see that instability in
itself so there's power to be able to
look at the evidence on your own and
make that judgment call
i think the next question we have here
is more on the data analysis what do you
recommend
running a pad normal for endometrial
tissue
are there other types of cancer tissue
that need a normal mesh too
so we develop the assay with the aim of
not requiring
a paranormal tissue sample and the
sensitivity is comparable
to running both a normal and a matched
tumor
in colorectal and gastric research
samples however
we do recommend running a normal match
for endosamples as micro satellite
instability is difficult to detect in
the sample type due to
very small often one to two base pair
changes in about 20 percent
of the msi high cases i'm not aware of
other cancer types that pose similar
challenges
but i'm also not sure that that research
has been done
in cancers where uh that have
low msi frequency since it's hard to
acquire a large enough number of msi
samples
in those cases i think that makes for a
good research
project though to look into
so it sounds like we do not need a pet
samples to actually analyze
data but how does the software make the
analysis without
the extra mesh pad control
for the tumor only analysis there's a
database of samples known to be stable
that the algorithm compares to
and this accounts for any natural
variation in the wheel size that's out
there
that sounds perfect uh for for the for
the utility in the lab
so i think we have another question
coming up more on the
markers that are being used on the
panels uh
how are these markers selected and how
are they prioritized
yeah so there are 13 msi markers on the
panel
eight of the markers have been
historically used in the detection of
colorectal cancer
and we've added five proprietary markers
and we selected these five because they
were shown to be monomorphic
which means that they have the same
allele across multiple ethnic
populations
and these fire markers were also
selected because they showed high
sensitivity across
multiple cancer types not just
colorectal and because they're
you know they're just the right the
right size of around
20 base pairs too large of a homopolymer
and you see more
natural variation of homopolymer size
than normal samples
which challenges msi interpretation and
too small
and the instability profiles are harder
to see
thank you i think the next question we
can go
to uh is more lynching syndrome i think
you covered this very much earlier in
the presentation
uh that both germline and somatic
mutation
play a role in mmr deficiency in lynch
syndrome patient or is it just germline
in the lint lynch syndrome in and of
itself i'm pretty sure that's just the
hereditary form so
germline but msi
can result from somatic mutations as
well
thank you i think the next one we can
look into
is um the clinical comparison i think
for the negative predictive value and
positive predictive value analysis
how is the true positive and true
negative
determined is it clinically
we use the the truth call
as the whatever result was from the
immunohistochemistry
so each of these um samples were stained
with
four different mmr proteins and if they
had
deficiencies in any one of the four
those were considered
dmmr and that was the truth
that we considered
so uh so the numbers that presented
there uh is
uh including this any this concordance
data
so it's not kind of like the true
positive or true negative
or is it just a concordance data
yeah you can i would think of it more of
concordance to ihd
i see thank you very much the next
question uh
we have here is more of a sample type um
that's true msi analysis software have
any peak normalization during automated
calling
uh it's a sample input from ffp only or
blood as well
okay two per question so for the first
part yes there
is normalization in the algorithm
because uncorrected
large amplification differences between
the tumor and normal samples
could trip up the algorithm so we do
account for that
in the uh calling of msi
and but the peak normalization isn't
shown in the electroferogram so you
can't actually see that normalization
happening on the visual side although
that's a feature that we might add to
the software in the future
and the second part of that question was
i think it was uh can you use blood as
well
um and so we developed the assay for and
tested it on ffpe samples
although we do have current customers
that are trying it on liquid biopsy
samples and the results are really
similar
we plan to put an app note or poster out
later sometime this year showing the
performance in blood samples
but i don't have a time frame for that
yet
okay so um just one last question before
we conclude the discussion um
can we use the current gene method
software
uh on the essays that you just shared
with us
you can use gmapper but it doesn't
support automated calling and reporting
if you want those features then you'll
need to use the msi analysis software
but if you'd still like to use gene
mapper to help troubleshoot for instance
then you can absolutely do that and
you'll be able to find the analysis
settings and panels
on our msi software webpage in the near
future
and um i think that's all the time we
have
as a final reminder any questions that
were submitted
and are not answered today by our
speakers will be addressed through email
and uh with that i would like to uh
thank our speaker
cavaldo for sharing his insights on the
msi
thank you very much thank you for your
time
sure so next our next speaker
who will join us is dr hirosu
from japan dr hirosuk
is the chief researcher shinog analysis
center
in yama yamanashi central hospital in
japan
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
this research is focused on the genetic
profile
liquor biopsy and translational research
using clinical specimens today
he will be sharing with us on the topic
cancer genomics research
on tumor clonality and like biopsy
this presentation will be in japanese
however english caption will be made
available
if any question arrives during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your question
following his presentation
with that please join me in welcoming
dr hirosu now i will turn the
presentation
over to him
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
foreign
but
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you dr hirosu for that outstanding
presentation
unfortunately uh dr hirosu can't join us
live today as he is being called away
at the very last minute this also means
that dr hiroso is
unable to answer your question live
today
however please rest assure we will
consolidate your question
to him and get back to you through email
after the event
thank you for joining us for the last
two session for the clinical oncology
session
from here we will take a 15-minute break
before we start the next session
so please go and have good coffee visit
our booth at the exhibition hall
there are seven different books
segmented by field of interest
learn about some of our exciting
promotion that is made available to you
there will be thermo official
representatives at each booth
looking into any enquiries you might
have
on top of that please participate in our
scavengers hunting game
look out for icons in the environment to
win special prizes
lastly there will be a pop-up survey
appearing in a minute please help us to
complete the survey
let us know how we do with that
thank you very much it's been extremely
enjoyable speaking to all of you
thank you and i will see you in another
15 minutes sign thank you